Rick Grimes has been a staple of the
walking dead since the show first
started back in 2010 season 9 has teased
his demise throughout and in the latest
episode of the show we finally learned
his fate throughout this video I'll be
discussing the plot of Rick's final
episode in full detail so there will be
heavy spoilers the last few episodes
have been some of the show's best so I
highly recommend that you check them out
before watching this video without the
way I'm definition and I roon it so you
don't have to in episode 4 rick was
dealt a betrayal about the hands of
Maggie and Daryl our hero was forced to
fight the latter which led to both
falling down a pier and being attacked
by a group of walkers though they
managed to escape and rekindle their
friendship they still had to deal with
the undead both was set upon by hordes
of zombies which forced Rick to lead
them away from the newly built bridges
that the civilization had created riding
horseback Rick was thrown from his ride
at which left him impaled on a steel
rebar which is where the prior episode
ended episode 5 picks up immediately
after this with Rick trying to escape
the crowd that surrounds him all whilst
dealing with the devastating damage that
the impalement has led to Rick
eventually makes it back to the bridge
that he was so desperate to protect but
in his seemingly final act the character
blows it up in order to protect his
family and friends though on lookers who
witness him apparently die mourn for him
we Lyn he was in fact thrown from the
bridge by the explosion and is
eventually found by Jadis who radios the
mysterious helicopter that has been
mentioned throughout season 9 to come
and pick him up
episode 5 then takes another unexpected
turn with there being a huge time jump
The Virginian field where Rick was last
seen becomes overgrown with foliage and
a new pack of survivors emerge the squad
includes Magne Yumiko Luke Connie and
Kelly who are all characters from the
highly successful comic book series with
Rick in fact being alive The Hollywood
Reporter has repealed that AMC are using
the character in three more original
Walking Dead movies the first is to
begin production in 2019 in an interview
with Hollywood Reporter Lincoln revealed
that there were originally three endings
planned but they stuck with this one as
it felt most right for the
personally I feel like the ending was a
cop-out the season has lauded the
characters final few episodes over our
head for a while and it felt like the
show was finally going to have some real
consequences that I feel slightly robbed
of Game of Thrones has shown that you
can still kill off major characters and
work with what remains and I feel like
the creative team didn't want to Foley
laid their cards on the table or take
the risk so they've just done something
that will give them an easy way out I
can imagine it annoying a lot of fans
and with the show already facing a lot
of backlash and this will continue to
grow I will of course stay watching it
like many but the Walking Dead's
becoming more of a chore rather than the
show that I used to live in the door so
what are your thoughts on the latest
episode of The Walking Dead do you think
Rick had is satisfying send-off and what
are your predictions for what direction
the plot will take moving forward
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video make sure you head
over to my site definition cata UK where
I'm currently doing a read-through and
review of The Walking Dead graphic novel
series this is a channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like give
me a subscribe to definition thanks for
taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace I'm not even
lying he flew away in helicopter is how
most of my toy games as a kid would end
when I just didn't have the imagination
to think of anything better it's such
bad rain
you